hello everyone and welcome to today's
session of the bd2k fundamentals of data
science webinar series where each week
we prevent present a new lecture of
giving us a background in the
foundations of data science and it's a
real pleasure to introduce today's
speaker our name is soooo Machado Scylla
is professor of medicine at the
university of california san diego and
chair of the department of biomedical
informatics Mesilla has had a
distinguished career she received her MD
from university of são Paulo received
your MBA I'm to Stanford and are the
1990s received her PhD and this is marc
newson I can't say that I'm pleased that
you got her PhD with me but it makes me
very very proud
oh so has lots of honors our machines
elected member of the American Society
of Clinical in this investigation and a
fellow american college of medical
informatics she edited Journal of the
American Medical Genetics association
but most important she directs a project
to the b2k program related to finding
accessing interoperating with and we're
using data and that's gonna be the topic
of the steelers talked this morning
before the sewer speaks let me remind
everyone that you're all on mute
people are so many people listening in
to this call are as you have questions
during the car that talked to today
please I put your questions into the
chat box and we'll be sure that we can
send those questions too so for her
comment at the end of the hour and we're
looking forward to hearing what was so
it has to say go ahead think American
thank the organizers for the opportunity
to present this project which is the
data discovery index consortium that we
are living together with collaborators
from the university of michigan
university of oxford also university of
texas houston so i'm presenting on
behalf of all of them and now try to
monitor the question box and as I speak
so i would like to start with motivation
for this and then
this is one dead I'm personally
interested in for example a question
about could i get all data about
astrocytomas with TB 53 mutations and
then in particular and interested in
stage two type of tumor cells can I get
images can I get medical records can I
get other type of data so I products
assess survival I couldn't assess
recurrence in other items of interest
and believe it or not if you try to do
that today it is very calm person and
you don't find everything that you
should so we started with the data
discovery index consortium with the goal
of help users find share data with the
prototype for data discovery and next a
search engine in internet operate in the
cons so in accordance to the fair
principles our primary goals are to find
it and access data in the other eye and
our are also desirable but is not are
not the total focus of our projects as
of now our goal is to do for data with
PubMed did four papers that is make them
discoverable and make them accessible
biocatalyst started effectively about
one-and-a-half years ago with our set of
priorities and i'm pleased to say that
after one year and a half we have a lot
to show this is slide from wrong
our goal is that he presented and our
all hands meeting that happened
adjusted for a few weeks ago in he had
attested to show others or to show the
bio candy team where we fit into the
digital data Commons for NIH and his
slide here shows the stack of items that
are anticipated for the commons in how
data and reference data sets are such an
important foundation for that and with
that all digital object
objects as well with software with
systems workflows in someone and this is
all on top of the computer platform
which kind of can be clouds can be high
performance computing clusters so in
this slide I just show you my view
debt-free curated data turns into
curated data and is annotated its method
are included and then analytics happen
in analytics it is the priority of many
of the bd2k centers of excellence and
this is how it all ties together their
hosted in the cloud the cluster server
in our case we do a lot with a HIPAA
data not necessarily and bio candy but
in many other projects that is human
subjects data that needs to be protected
with a certain type of regulations and
it's often the case that you combine
this data so in my example you are
looking for medical records
I determining the rate of recurrence the
survival of a particular type of tumor
so you want to combine publicly
available data with HIPAA compliant data
and then when you join items you create
another day a second and that other data
set can also be annotated and be
reprocessed and enter into an analytical
process so that's why i believe it all
comes together in we should join forces
and in terms of indexing all these
objects so we can reuse them and can
make them reproduce it'll the analysis
reproducible later in journals and
publications are not out of the look
because they are the end product of all
of this and they're a little bit of as a
circle in a loop in themselves so the
bio caddy project the main components
are working groups metadata
specification software development
collaborations and administration
I actually proposed this project
initially thinking it would be a risk
research project but clearly it was also
a in engineering and technical project
but most of all it is a social project
in which collaborations are critical
engagement of a large community makes
the project much more impactful so the
way we view bio caddy and its data
discovery index prototype is that we
will develop a search engine in it that
people can access to show what it is
involved in getting digital objects
index this search engine as with
anything else can be replaced by another
search engine another front end and
someone but what's important is that the
data and the objects get indexed in such
a way that this search engines can find
them
additionally we want pilot projects for
mother institutions to be integrated
into the data discovery X so people can
develop different portions of this DDI
in together we we get much further than
we would otherwise an important aspect
also is that we want to index data
aggregators that means we want to index
other instances we don't want to
reproduce that work and in fact we want
to make sure users can get to them when
they are searching for particular
objects like i said in our case we're
searching across a wide variety of data
types and this aggregators tend to focus
on a particular datatype in are much
more detail then we would ever be able
to be if we set out to index absolutely
everything ourselves so one example in
this will be given here is the omics
data discovery that data index project
that are shown in collaboration with the
tart bd2k center and with the LX here
colleagues so we have here is it is just
another illustration of we we have big
data sets for example from the NIH
comments that we will index we are
indexing at this moment we are also
providing links our index to aggregator
services so this was a pilot project
that having him pick up leads in
collaboration with bio caddy and the
heart bd2k center and it's the omics
discovery index so again I test its own
search engine and it has indexed all
makes objects to a very high extent so
what we do is integrate with this
aggregator in and therefore not
replicate the work but let's say we were
trying my search we would find the Onyx
datasets on astrocytomas but we would
also find images hopefully and find
clinical data so that's the goal of
being an umbrella in X for all this
other ones that we are help integrate so
the arm XD I is is one of several
examples but it's the one that was a
supplement funded to the project and
happy to to display here there are
others as well so the goal is to get
this repository the data sets and the
state of things and just that metadata
so we can do this
Boober index into a search engine
provide users with waiters will result
that are way too in order of relevance
to them in order to do that we have a
technology server that extends Squared's
and also a ranking engine so what are
some of you have seen our presentation
at the last video 2k meeting we were in
the beginning of the rodent or in the
middle ear and we were designing the
prototype so we can showcase what the
indexing is all about where we are now
this data engine data man is already
deployed and it's in version one point
out that you can see and together with
it it's the data net metadata which is
also in a finalized at this point so the
front end of data man looks like this
there are 23 repositories now many more
being indexed as we speak attend data
types for pilot projects integrated and
about 600 for 9,000 datasets at the
moment also at the bottom here you will
see the pilot projects that have already
been integrated with three more to come
in the way the pilot projects work is we
issue a request for applications and we
haven't a a peer-review process and then
issue subcontracts to the projects that
were deemed most relevant and most
integrated oil with bio caddy and here
we have a data mad search engine how it
looks like i encourage you all to go to
data Madoc org and try it out for
yourselves
there are filtering by facets a data
type and repository by an accessibility
and authorization and so keep in mind
that in order to filter by accessibility
would do need to have the metadata about
that and that's why one of our working
groups has focused on we can again
filter by repository specific facets and
so on so upcoming our path ahead is the
depending on a variety of factor but the
goal is to make a difference in the way
that they are shared so we have a
dataset retrieval challenge we are still
have been working groups for certain
items that we are fine-tuning and
integrated projects so in terms of
working groups that I talked about there
are fundamental piece of biochem the
related to use cases that's how we
elicited use cases to working groups
defined criteria for inclusion defined
how we will do with identifier 'he's
defined amount of data specifications
and go intervals would look like
usability testing someone and partly
also data citations and links to
applications and then finally the
evaluation so this we're all working
groups that we created surrounding the
data discovery next consortium so that
we could get two members from the
community to participate in the creation
of it so one of the initial working
groups is how we interact with other
bd2k centers in another programs of NIH
so we developed some supplemental
projects that will present one of them
then quickly with other centers and
shown here and there is one upcoming
with links as well on visualization and
ranking as i said it open different
modules that can be there incorporated
to data mad as a search engine or being
a search engine in themselves
we also have been in contact with common
fun program about the data sets that
they would like to be in next into we
had the joint meetings
also this training webinar we also plan
to participate in the cloud pilots when
the identifier zwi decided will not
meant identifiers through bio candy but
we will use identifiers that fully
resolved to an uri and we should also
maintain a set of landing pages for each
of the datasets index including forward
ones that may no longer exist so we need
to document
the persistence of this data set
yeah identified a working group but was
led by Jeff granthi and the there was a
minimal identifier pilot in a
collaboration with other centers are the
bd2k centers that is also ongoing as
well as the citation implementation
pilot with the force 11 organization led
by tim clark this data citation
implementation project was a supplement
to bio caddy in allowed even more
members of the community to contribute
to our efforts another working group was
led by susannah sand so not very
important related to the metadata
specifications and has gone through
summer several versions now it's um 2.1
and the important thing to emphasize it
was the ride both from the use case
approach which we call a top-down abro
approach shown in the left hand side as
well as a bottom-up approach that is
looking into what we had as metadata
already in trying to reconcile several
metadata strategies in order to come up
with the minimum specifications for dats
which is the data tag suite which is
based on the the same principle with
Jack switch which is the journal article
x wheat meaning at one point once that
specification it's very well understood
data produces can submit data or submit
metadata to bio candy in in the same way
that journals the journal publisher
submit data to apartment so that's our
goal
the working group representation was
from several institutions and end with
some some of them are listed here and
this is to say that it wasn't us
deciding on a matter
data and specification but consultation
with many many initiatives we also did
use cases and testing benchmarks and the
resume reports you can find it how user
analysis was done in usability tests we
also as part of this created testing
benchmarks so that's another
contribution that we received as being
long-lasting because it's a very
laborious work in terms of annotated and
confirming and validated rankings of
retrievals so this is now available in
its will be used for our challenge and
after that it will be a available to the
community so that you take this were uh
essentially created this benchmark
datasets instantiate in the queries
running search engines and manually
annotated equality of results we also
had a working group on data citation
metrics because there are important in
order to reward those who share the data
and the goals were to have qualitative
and quantitative metrics that would talk
about issues such as when the date data
will produce provenance downloads and
and then ranked results in and criteria
to restrict search that could depend on
such metrics for example the most
popular datasets that is the most
downloaded so one so this group out
specifically with this issue and the
report is also available online another
a working group that is very important
it was to decide which data repositories
with index to get started with our
search engine and that is an important
distinction between a search engine that
simplifies everything we wanted to
convert least some degree of filtering
and quality control
to which datasets appear or at least in
the order in which they appear in an
hour
search engine so we have come up with
some criteria here related to prominence
sustainability school quality and axis
and also with a repository submission
workflow so that we repositories can
approach as weak or we approach them and
then we work out on how we should out to
make this metadata mapping into our
specifications and how to exert quality
throw and into the mapping and so on so
again anyone who has a repository out
there once it to appear right away in
bio carrion data mad please do let us
know because we are into a very active
process of doing this many Impostors
been indexed asthma speak in
accessibility meadow was also very
important so led by George outer from
the University of Michigan have a
working group decided what would be the
initial set of metadata related to
authorization of education and access it
and this is also has been incorporated
into deaths 2.1 and why is that
accessibility important because we do
not want to limit ourselves to public
data only we know that there are several
very valuable data sets that are under
access control into user should know
about the exist and then know how so the
conditions by which they could be
accessible so
privacy is very important to us in one
important project supplemental project
that relates to it is named count
everything and that is for secure
aggregating counts of relevant patients
across different data types so we
partnered with the md 2k center
with the picture center and i'll also
the Global Alliance for genomics and
health which is the translational
genomics enter out of UC Santa Cruz in
order to come up with the secure
aggregated counts
why is it important for bio candy the
situation is as follows remember i was
looking for astrocytomas and I was
suppose I was looking for ones that had
mutations and tp53 and I want to go the
whole sequence of that particular gene
if i go by matter data only i would know
that
yes i have data whole genome sequence
data for this this patients that I act
however i would not know how many have a
particular mutation so if it's a data
set that has no patience with mutations
maybe it's not as important to me as
having another data set in which twenty
percent of the patients have mutations
in that particular gene of interest so
in order to organize the way i would be
requesting those datasets because they
are under axis control it would be
important to know which one has more of
the characteristics of the patients are
looking for so that's why counting
everything would be important but as you
know counting can compromise privacy so
that's where we designed this in such a
way that it's done through encryption
and out of those communications in the
aggregation is than in a secure
environment so this is a supplemental
project that involved this three other
centers of excellence this under bd2
case interest continue on the the list
of working groups also a working group
to rank search results our land from the
university of texas houston was
conducted the reporters online there
recommendations are to empirically
determine which ranking algorithm from
the elasticsearch family will be best
for us based on evaluations against
reference sets and logs of user behavior
since we now have a user bases there
continuously accessing data man in
provide alternative ranking based on
user preferences so this also is
evolving as we have more users to our
search engine and user evaluation
criteria also very important and we're
still conducting does in terms of saying
how do we know we got there that we have
a good product for users use usage
itself might not be a good metric there
can be other measures of impact so this
particular working group was working on
that repository contact workflow this
was led by George outer how do we
develop this workflow in terms of having
a repository to index who starts the
process how is it is tracked in so one
how we prioritize those that come to us
there is now a committee that has
developed processes in his following up
with this particular aspect natural
language processing is also an important
aspect of our index because as you know
it is very important to extract
structure data from narrative text
actually we have just issued in
extension on our data set retrieval
challenge sign up so that we came up as
is a challenge that has a very high
monetary award which will be in the form
of a subcontract to the winners that
there can be more than one around fifty
thousand dollars for this particular
challenge so if you're interested please
do login to buy candy . orange
and look into this challenge the way it
works is that the winners will have
their algorithms incorporated into our
damage prototype and we will make full
use of the the their work and we will
compensate for that as well in an
independent panel of judges will be
making that determination
so also for ingestion and indexing i
won't go through many many details i
would ask you to primarily follow the
boxes that are shown here in this
l-shape format because that's it
the process by which the core
development team led by Jeff breathy in
by your shoe are developing this
ingestion of data sources in order to
get the metadata and there are important
interactions here and i would say that
with schema.org and with cedar so with
schema.org we want to be perfectly
aligned so that the metadata can conform
to to schema.org so it can be found by
other search engines and not only data
man also did a collaboration with cedar
is such that remember them the word data
sets that were not already aggregated
and that the data contributors would be
annotating those datasets were creating
those made a metadata populated the
metadata for us and we rely on cedar
that is a center that is developing left
my mark using that is developing this
forms in smart forms so that data
producers can annotate their data sets
we are also the deaths metadata model
was developed by working group led by
susanna from Oxford
and we are creating this metadata
transformations so that it becomes
easier to reconcile all this strategies
their requirements for the metadata as
ice mentioned before we're driven by
multiple stakeholders so it as i said is
as a social process of reconciling all
of this and making it so that we're all
swimming in the same direction it was
collaboration across this multiple
working groups that i mentioned before
in order to get this ingestion and
indexing going through a process that
initially is like a number one there is
a submission format we need to develop
adapters and someone going on involving
true number three in which we hope and
we are structuring ourselves to scale so
that similar to how journalist currently
provided command data providers will
provide data to debts without this more
manual process that is currently
involved in populating the initial 8am
at so so as we evolve we become happier
and we also scale how did the index and
housing conferencing it is we also want
to enhance metadata that this will be a
continuous project and process and will
continue to involve the community in
that as well as incorporating elements
of natural language processing as we
progress the final document preparation
again that is a pipeline here into in
order to be scalable the pilot public
process is skilled mobile horizontally
large datasets before and has been
pipeline and that's 21 models are in the
works right now and there is a high
volume of up
operations and the dedicated this at the
moment we want to populate the index as
much as possible
I scalable index services as well we
rely heavily on elasticsearch in we have
also we are also creating a P is for
developers so they can build their own
modules and utilize the index data in
their own ways
this is another pilot project that i
wanted to highlight pilot projects are
like I said those that are completed
through a peer-review process in are
awarded to the ones that are getting
more relevant to bio caddy at this
moment so one of them was is like my
Christmas golfer from lawrence berkeley
national laboratory laboratory in
collaboration with other programs
displayed here in Crisco is to use
github yellow and mark down in order to
make as he puts it making a metadata of
annotation fun so it's a project that
again he uses the capabilities of github
in order to have outers put their
metadata in there into this is ongoing
but we have seen as demonstrations of it
already and it is again and showing
alternatives to what we had originally
thought the annotation process could be
in this is the value of engaging the
community we always have some good ideas
coming up and we can incorporate them or
put different modules into our own
development another bio caddy pilot
project was it should to the University
of Utah in into metadata discovery and
integration to support repurposing
heterogeneous data using the oven
further platform and this is again and
a way up indexing that this particular
group in utah has proposed and we said
let's yeah let's try that too because
the more Minds think about this process
the better
another one and to complete the world
three this past year was the visibility
study of index and clinical research
data using hr7 fire which is a standard
for clinical data exchange that is very
popular these days and it's a pilot
project on harvesting strategy for the
data discovery index led by harold so
break from the mayo clinic so they had
three the liver balls one was matted
data harmonization the other one was
indexing the began phenotype variables
and the third one was exposing metadata
schema.org which as I mentioned before
is also our goal with that with our
metadata specification so were we were
very happy to have this three pilot
projects this year and will have the
natural language processing next year
and this are all again available for the
community to come up with the best idea
so we essentially see bio caddies having
the the data shop components is very
technical indexing Lee lincoln Tomb
articles of college based tools we can
see the data Showcase which is the front
end the that uses elasticsearch but
essentially it's about the graph going
interface how we visualize how the
usability of the tool is meeting
expectations and then there's a whole
data market which again its social
aspect of it that is very important
because there need to be incentives for
data sharing and for well for people to
annotate data very well and this
incentives currently are somewhat
obscure
and then date citation at works need to
develop because the same way as
application citations became the
currency of academic metrics the data
citations might become in the future at
least an important part of a large
ecosystem so in an hour
bio Kathy data shop and showcase we see
as the repository is contributing as
it's something happens inside the shop
and then the products are displayed in a
in an easy to and see fashion so that
the researchers our clients or customers
can decide what they want to take out of
the store or not I as I said that the
data market needs to be developed is not
fully developed by locality is one front
end of it or data man is one front end
of it that can be honors in again the
currency forward for data has not been
well defined so it's very exciting to be
at this point in time we were helping to
find all just elements for the day the
NIH data Commons into more than data we
also see it's other digital objects to
heaven this value and movie software
will being soft assistance package as
doctors package as the m's or other
sorts of value that will be provided so
we are with the help of a large
community trying to create the market to
find the market and create the first
tools so that after it do it exists and
others can come up with even better
tools and even better ways of indexing
of accessing so on so we are at the
beginning of a long journey
so here's the road map created by
the University of Texas colleagues as
you see we have a matter of milestones
from before we are still running their
and their public releases of the new
versions scheduled and they have
improvements in a variety of from
features as determined by the community
so please do experiment with data med
don't expect to see everything in there
but it's there so you get the idea and
you demand our datasets and you demand
improvements in the user interface into
in coverage of the data sets that we
have right now so our journey that is a
poor picture that I took in the genna's
berg airport if you have an opportunity
please do take a better one but it says
something very important and it says if
you want to go fast you go alone if you
want to go far
then you go together is an African
proverb and we see bio caddy as in in
that states that we never has to go fast
but we were also asked to go far so we
have engaged a large community to go far
with us to have an initial prototype and
then engage the community to challenge
the community to have better prototypes
in to help us index this unit volume of
data that are out there unused in a way
that makes a moral value for our dollars
so with that I was also instructed to
leave plenty of time for discussion so i
have here that the two things that I
want you to remember from this talk is
by okay . org damage . work so that you
can fully understand what we're doing
through our consultation with the
website and experimentation with the
search engine so again i would like to
thank the organizers for having given me
the opportunity to do this i did not
list here all collaborate
leaders for this project in fear that I
would miss somebody and with so many
collaborating you know and more than a
hundred at this point that would
certainly happen so i would like to
thank all collaborators all members of
the executive committee of biochem who
have teamed up to come up with the best
of both worlds
you know it's a consortium that would
put the best nights to work into this
very very challenging problem so mark
think thank you again for the
opportunity thanks for so that was great
our I was encouraging all the people who
are dialed into this webinar to post
questions since everyone is muted please
put your questions into the chat box and
we'll try to get those and as we can so
please put your questions in the chat
box now and will feed them to sew a
little before we do that let's go only
asked you you you ended your talk
showing a roadmap and my caddy has a
very ambitious goal
how do you know when you're done you any
sense for what is your number of
repositories what is the number of data
sets out there and how can you never
know when to stop working
yeah well against them that's why we had
a working group on that right but but
also yeah i see we have a lot to do
still and i can say it has been such a
fast-paced project that sometimes we
don't even have time to stop and think
you know I of the what's next cool how
do we know when we're done and we think
at this phase there is so much to be
done that i can see that the end very
soon so it in contrast with the
publication world in which there was a
market already there were your journals
existed they were publishing they were
having their own land
sites and so 1 i'm so in contrast to
publications data are more complicated
because it's not as organized as that
market was so at this point we're just
seeing the tip of the iceberg that data
sets that most people know and have used
accepted they're scattered all around
and accept that as a user of a
particular type of data let's say for
made clinical data i know that we're to
tap into the sources but when I jump
into image data I don't know or a mix
are others so never so much out there
that we don't even know that that's
important that this community's
specialized on this data types be in
this journey together with us or we
don't miss anything but it is a very
important question but one did it and
unfortunately don't have necessarily a
good answer for you right now I I just
see you know so much ahead of us that I
I can't see the end at this point
do you have any estimates for what the
denominator is about what what what how
much biomedical data is out there and
what fraction can you possibly access
your body
yes well apart from question no I think
that the good thing is you know at least
the repository is we know which ones
they are
what what they're doing and we also know
those repositories related to articles
right because their words are
increasingly more prominent in more
available
what we don't know and actually what you
don't know if we really want is and from
the long tail of those data sets that
have not been in next in our potentially
available but not findable we don't know
the quality of all of that so so how do
you know that something is good enough
to appear in the search engines that
as quality control on top of it right
and you may say well maybe it's not us
worth doing that and let the users exert
that quality control as of today in this
may change in the future but i believe
that it's important to get started with
some sense of quality control first in
there for many data sets that yes been
produced by one lab were kept there but
not share that there might be some
reason why they were not shared so where
will not be addressing those needed i
think as we progress and if we find that
the denominator is not that you just and
then there is a case for indexing
everything but probably what we'll find
is it will pluck to what some point but
again i can tell at this point I think
it will take you know I'm not a 34 years
for us to be at that stage that we can
really and assess and be picky about
this or then ok we're going to get some
questions from the audience of probably
the most important comment that we've
seen so far country Marjorie Mitchell
who says you you're doing awesome work
thank you thank you
okay are you have a question asking
whether imaging data can be indexed by a
caddy can it being linked with omics
data and ultimately bio can give you one
stop shopping so that you can have a
single search that will provide results
from riding these kind of data sources
that is Michael yeah and that is the D
when I mentioned that very first use
case i want to have alldata about this
particular condition because i want to
you know correlated I want to find
recurrence through the tumor through
images or through data that shows
increase and sizes and so on so that's
the is exactly the point of getting it
and uber index that would then . to the
sources that have more detailed
information and dad so max there's a
certain repositories if thats imaging
there's also through the bd2k centers
excellent sources of indexing of images
so i think that our point is exactly
this integration you find things that
you didn't know about another question
or are mentions that I alluded to
aggregating patient data and points to
the problems and I think you need
patient identifiers that make it easy to
bring patient data together and question
is how do you deal with that problem how
do you deal with missing data hey do
double counting data what are the
challenges are in doing this kind of
aggregation that this chances are
multiple I mean they not only come from
the privacy end of things but did
exactly what you mentioned the
duplication of patients across different
datasets it's a huge problem today for
research studies so a body will not
again how I will be very happy when
we're at that point but right now it's
more of the point of that of this exists
in this count everything project was the
first attempt to see how we would link
right because one dataset has mutations
another dataset as and sensor data and
other data seconds clinical data
assuming we have the same patient
representing and all this three how we
would do a secure linkage in absolute
privacy preserving secure linkage of
records so we could do this
deduplication so that's a very important
research area that I encourage more
people to get involved because it's
really and going to be a bottom back in
the future
ok Carl area that is how is the
identification manage my body cavity
again we do not add don't enter the data
sets
therefore the the identification is not
an issue because we're mostly dealing at
the metadata level so if you want to all
african-american patients with t p53
mutation of a certain type initially
what we can . is two data sets that have
that type of metadata that would have
great race and ethnicity and would have
mutations or it would have gene
information but unless we don't enter
the data that we can't count right that
the number so at this point we
identification through our index is not
an issue
what's more questions coming with so
this one is interesting
are you have any tips for searching with
data med of people have intuition about
how to optimize your google searches but
either any good your mystic soror are
ways in which users can optimize their
efficiency in exploring data with data
searches which is something that is not
necessarily intuitive most people
yeah well what i would do is I'll go to
advanced search because that might not
be immediately obvious in the interface
but there is just as input meant away
not to use the and just going and type
which researches but to structure it
better I'm trying to get to the slide it
has day at the interface here and yeah
here so seed the terrorism that the
right side and advanced search
I think that's the best way to go about
it and then as you get your answers you
can filter by the repositories by the
data types on this left-hand side and
you can also check the synonyms that
it's getting for you because the engine
room once you type something at the time
it uses that terminology store search
should go about synonyms and expand on
hierarchically that concept so so I
think that those would be ways to get
started and also feedback let me put it
here you have feedback something we
should be filtering by and we're not
doing that that would be very important
for us to know as well please do
contribute your comments are a lot of
lies the question as Howard errors and
inconsistencies bound flag and corrected
you actually have a mechanism giving
feedback to the repository of managers
yes
so now i would use this getup you click
here and you or put your issue there so
that someone can respond to you and if
those are corrections are needed
that's an excellent way to provide us
with that information
ok are two related questions one which
is how can someone get a list of all the
collaborators in bio candy and our
librarians working on the project
yes there are librarians the list who
but if you go by a headed . or
unfortunately I we need to work on the
interfaces if you go to the working
groups you will see everyone listed
under a working group there so i would
say the list is scattered into the
working groups there isn't a
consolidated list but if that's
desirable this something that we should
probably do because then I can put a
link on my acknowledgement slides to to
that particular list and that will cover
everyone great idea thank you
ok also you stated that you have certain
expectations about searching data when
you created at amid and questioned wants
to know do anything surprise you are in
your findings as you created the the
tool
yeah well it is still surprising me
because if i were to say I'm satisfied
and I can do that query in the beginning
that that was something I really wanted
to do it as a friend of the family I
wanted to know what is the survival for
a particular age group every young
person and i think i'm not satisfied yet
you know we can find some certain things
there right now but we don't have enough
imaging uh-huh repositories and I know
that those are coming so so it's not
like we're not able to bet it's not
populated to the extent that i would
like at this point i mean as much better
than if i go on google and search for it
because it essentially it very hard to
find anything that is more data-centric
in the current google search engine but
still you get my surprise is that it's
not a simple you know I started this
project with a much more naive approach
as this is a lot of work but it's simple
and now it's it's a lot of work and it's
not simple yes we sure are
another question how are you encouraging
search to deposit their data into
repositories is this just a lot more
work for them than what is by ok doing
to get access to more data
yeah so again that's where the data
citation groups were working on it and
and now so what the incentives are I
think we do need help with that because
remember when it happened that journals
started requiring the positive data in
order to publish an article people
started worn it again not perfect master
data but at least data were the
President and someone and it so happened
that the were repositories ready for
that
right what happens now is there are
certain data types in certain modalities
that you don't have repositories or I
mean you may have but they're not as
recognizable as those were when the
journals made that requirement so I I
think we need to create again this
market for data repositories better are
beyond what exists already four other
data types and then when publications
which are still important for the
academic community and require that and
then have the funding agencies provide
incentives for people to to comply with
that when she wants to know how users
might be engaged in providing feedback
to the data that developers and how do
you ensure that you're creating a search
engine that people actually want versus
one that you actually do you think they
might watch
yes exactly and that's where again I'll
get to this point of providing the
feedback through github or through
contacting any of us because each person
has a different idea of what they would
want from the search engine right on
data so I that's also the reason we had
this pilot project solicitations and so
one because it is different and every
one is different we want to know how can
we cover the you know the eighty percent
are most common expectations in and then
also learn about other so that in the
future we can do so best thing is to
provide feedback on through this good
time
link sure yeah so now
it are we have very little time left we
can be very selective bananas and
imposing some questions to your so uh
here's one that says a dataset actually
gets used and we use are rather as it is
that actually gets used and reused and
suitability for different purposes can
become clearer is your now in your
scheme were doing vision developing
rules for dating losers to stop moment
data suppliers metadata with usage knows
caveat bug reports etc
otherwise I guess how do you make data
med two-way yes
so that's one thing that we were
thinking to with more volume and if we
could for example we were looking at
edit screen right now if we could have
for each one of those entries the number
of stars right the reviews from people i
liked it or no I didn't like it at
similar to when you're buying a product
on Amazon I think that would be very
good and we do need to create that
feedback mechanism in here and then we
need to obviously it started getting
more a lot of usage to wait so that we
go from several reviews but i think
that's that's a goal that happily okay
are what Google a good question for
improving your users how can you say
something more about how bio County
actually facilitates data reuse yeah at
this point I wouldn't go to XR well
would say we're trying to address the
findability of it so indirectly if you
find it
you're more likely to read reuse it but
that's not a guarantee right it might
have access controls that you you are
not able to fulfill the requirements and
so on so I i think it's a step towards
and reusability but it's one of several
components that need to be in place so
that it can be reused in this feedback
again is very important because people
have to access
said two people have to use it and then
provide feedback
yes this was useful for me or no stated
set looked good and the outside but when
I got it's really not that useful
are we just not the end of the hour are
several questions would like to know how
to get ahold of your slides I will
provide it to get to the organizers and
now so let me make a point i'll put it
on the bio caddy dot org website
actually so and i'm looking at the
audience know that this talk was
recorded and will eventually be on the
website for the training coordinating
Center which is of providing an archive
of all as you an article summaries at
this point are we are out of time are
let me thank you soo Machado for was a
really exciting presentation let me
thank all of you for some really great
questions and our remind you that we do
this every weekend looking forward to
next week's presentation as well thanks
everyone thank you